so this obviously didn't work so
uh
let's get rid of all this
so single stage worked pretty well it
got us plenty high enough
um in fact we already beat that but we
now need to go back i mean we have to
remember that our contract now is to get
to 16 400 but we need to get to an area
now this is our new contract
so let's get rid of all these
notifications
it's like space version of facebook
right so we've got a test r10 sort of
rocket boosters so what are they i hear
you crying they're these
now
how many of these can we get away with
let's try four
because why not
so solid rocket boosters are a bit
different um from the engines we've been
using so far what we've been using so
far these liquid fueled engines um so
liquid engines are used uh in if you
think of a rocket you're thinking of a
liquid field engine that's where you
have what they call liquid fuel that
could be kerosene that could be some you
know complicated chemical concoction
and it's also got oxidizer
now the reason that you have liquid fuel
it's because it has a much higher
density
than
a gas obviously you know you can if you
if you imagine a massive room full of
gas if you liquidize that gas you're
going to put it down into a very small
container and
that means that you can have a much
smaller spacecraft which moves it around
so you have liquid fuel and then to
when you're burning that fuel you need
as much oxygen as possible to to
complete the combustion that's
ultimately what pauses for you know
creates the force you have a combustion
between fuel and oxygen which creates a
force in lots of different directions
but you focus it by this nozzle and
there's an awful lot about nozzle design
in um astronautics
so that's how most rockets work and of
course the other reason you need the
oxidizer of course is because if you're
firing in space there's no oxygen
whereas these
you have solid fuel now this this can be
a variety of things and it tends to be
pretty volatile stuff um
but they don't have any oxidizer so
these burn in the atmosphere they
weren't they wouldn't work in space um
and they are literally a light and leave
you know they they um
they they just burn they can't stop them
once they've started
so
what we're going to try and do to get
this contract it doesn't pay much money
but it's you know it's useful to show
you what these these things do
is we're
oh dear oh dear right okay so one thing
about what we're doing at the moment is
we're at the very start the space
program and this launch pad out there
can't deal with very much uh and our
spacecraft at the moment is too heavy
we're two tons overweight
so what we might then do
can we get away with three of these
just about okay
so what we'll do then is we'll use this
spacecraft and see if we can possibly
reach that area what we're probably
gonna have to do is probably gonna have
to put this into two stages such that
once these
uh
are burnt through they're a lot of
weight
they're they're an awful lot of weight
actually um
and they're just going to drag us down
so we'll see how we get going but this
is a new mission so we need a new pilot
and a new pilot is going to be jordan
mcgonagall and his spacecraft
is going to be biohazardo7
i'm not even going to ask mate where you
got that from uh
to be fair my room was a biohazard in
2007.
right jordan you sitting comfortably
it's the same view that i had in my
spacecraft so you know you're going to
get used to it look at this what's this
it's trackables all over the place
shameful right
so let's just have a quick look at the
map so we need to get over here
so
we need to angle ourselves
northeast
so that's
this way
yeah i'm a scientist yeah
right this is going to go like hell's
bells so brace yourselves three two one
it's quite spectacular oh my god
now the problem is
we are burning up an awful lot of solid
fuel and we're going to have an awful
lot of mass so watch the velocity down
here
when the solid rocket boosters are done
we are going quickly when the solid
rocket boosters are done our velocity is
going to jump right back down because we
haven't got the thrust from these guys
look it's tumbling like a rock
we're still gonna we're still
accelerating because we still got this
rocket but we're not accelerating as
fast
so
and we're calling back up right let's
just see so we're going in the right
direction
quite a little bit east actually
but i don't think we're going to make it
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa i think i'm going
in the wrong direction me no of course
not i'd be silly
yeah we were going in the wrong
direction
okay now what it's possible that we can
do
it's probably not going to work
oh look does something fall off i know
that must be the uh standard couple of
from last time
what we can do is wait till we get to
the apoapsis
so we'll just speed up time a little bit
so we can get there a bit faster
and what we can try and do is do a
lateral burn
so because we're plenty high enough
what we can try and do is burn sideways
and we'll see what that does to our
trajectory right
so
uh
oh it's beautiful this game
what direction we need to go we need to
go
oh actually that's a point i can turn on
navigation
to this point
so i think that means that we need to
burn in this direction
so we haven't got much fuel left so
let's see how
this changes our trajectory
so it's flattening out
but not enough
okay
that's fine
this is this is all good stuff
you'd think that a crew report from
space would be worth more than that this
is all good stuff right so let's let's
jettison this part of the ship
and i will see you guys back on the
ground
look at jordan look how happy he is
jordan game one xp
i i actually don't know what that means
okay so it looks like jordan oh jordan
you're actually a pilot oh that's really
useful okay um so jordan i think needs
to get one more xp and then he gets some
upgrades it becomes more effective but
you know we also got a lot of science
from that mission because we actually
went into space
so i think we actually have enough yeah
we actually have enough to unlock some
more parts
these are exactly what we need
so the parts that we just unlocked were
radial decouplers now
what we have here is a stack decouplers
that that decouples from the stack it's
literally it's like a linear thing
what the radial couplers do they
decouple radially so if we put three of
them on
you'll see that they appear as a stage
and if i whack these on top of them
what we have here then
is a new flight plan
so
what what we're going to now try and do
and we're going to keep we're going to
keep jordan in and we're going to keep
biohazard
07. that's our ship um what we're going
to do is we're going to fire all the
three engines together
in fact you know what i'm feeling
generous
i might whack on a bit more fuel
so what we're going to do is we're going
to burn all three all four of our
engines at once
and then once these engines are done
these these um solid rocket boosters
we're gonna jettison them using these
radio decouplers
we're gonna see
hopefully that's gonna be enough to get
us
where we're going
oh no it's oh it's too heavy
oh
slightly too heavy
that's really really really annoying
what can we do to lose a little bit of
weight jordan can i ask you just lose a
little bit of weight please you only
need to lose like
a hundred kilos okay maybe it's a bit
realistic can we just not take you
all right i think we're gonna have to
limit ourselves to just using two
solid rocket boosters
but
now that we're not casting them around
with us
this should be a bit better and the
other thing which we got actually
because how are we doing for weight
that's got plenty um we've got these
winglets
found lying by the side of the road um
what these do these gonna allow us to
have a little bit more aerodynamic
control
over the ship
uh i'll just put two on for now
it's not really ideal but it'll stop us
spinning not that we wear anyway
right let's see what we can do this time
so just to recap we now have three
engines and we're gonna fire all three
at once once these two have burnt out
i'm gonna hit space again and these
radio decouplers are going to force
these off the side
and then we're going to keep burning the
rest of this column
we'll see how high that gets us and we
now know that we don't want to go here
on the trackable we want to go here on
the trackable right let's go
children as i say yes so i can actually
control it i hope you can hear me how
loud these engines are
okay how are we looking
look we're actually going in the right
direction this is good this is very good
and the solid rockets are almost out of
fuel
there we go so we can adjust some of
them there they go wow
so
we use those we've got a bit more
prestige
now let's see
we didn't get us very high but we still
have an awful lot of fuel left
and we are going
ish in the right direction let's just
move ourselves a bit more laterally so
we're going to go closer
come on
yes that's what i want to see
how high do we need to be for this
sixteen thousand four hundred
i'll save my fuel right okay
don't know what because we're not out of
the atmosphere
oh flying you're jordan you're a dream
to fly with you make it so much easier
okay right
so
nice and high
now what we can do is we can actually
unlock a upgrade to the space station so
the the space center such that if i
click on a bit of an orbit
it will uh
allow me to see
given an amount of delta v in any given
direction
how it's gonna affect my orbit we can't
do that yet uh so we're just gonna have
to eyeball it but basically we just need
to boost this way we need to we need to
boost once we're here prograde so in the
same direction as we're going but what i
can do actually is uh
activate navigation so on our trackable
that is the direction
come back a little thing
right okay enough we're going to lock it
off there
um that's the direction that we want to
play in
playing
firing sorry i really should turn off
steam alerts that's really annoying i
wish oh i'd love to be playing c5 right
now
i just got brave new world and it's
amazing
right
so that's basically at the top of our
boat
now let's burn and see how this affects
our trajectory so there we go look look
how quickly this is uh flattening out
so where's that left us so in space we
don't have to worry about drag we now
need to burn a little bit
like this
so weird
just getting ourselves a little bit
higher because ultimately we do need to
be high up
i think actually
that would be a good idea
come on come on
don't run out of fuel yet please
oh we literally just ran out of fuel
okay
is that gonna be close enough
let's find out okay so we're just going
to warp
to near that location we're going to
coming down we're coming down in the
ocean that's the point actually
to minimize the effect of drag let's
jettison that you're a nice you're a
nice biohazardo seven i quite liked
you
i'm sorry we just couldn't have made you
a bit bigger it would have been nice
right
oh we're gonna be near enough i'm not
sure
we're definitely high enough
it's a question of whether we're near
enough
are we near enough
uh i don't think we are
it's actually difficult to reach this
one isn't it
no
i don't think
we're near enough i think i think jordan
you might have to fly us again
what's your view like
oh look you can see the flames
so this is uh this is this is the
atmosphere heating the spacecraft up to
thousands of degrees and that's uh
causing a flame what i didn't want to do
that
did you almost died in the fire for you
almost our first fatality then jordan
being a pilot that would have been a
really really big loss right let's
splash you down and let's try and do
this again
thanks for watching my playthrough
kerbal space program this is really the
youtube space program i suppose this is
where i am putting youtubers and their
spaceships into space if you would like
to be part of the kerbal space program
then please comment below and i will add
you to the roster and equally if you
have any ship names or if you have a
ship name that you yourself would like
to pilot please comment down below and i
will try and get you in the game lastly
if you have any suggestions for topics i
should talk about over the top of
gameplay when i remember to then please
also leave those down below in
particular i'm going to be looking at
rocket science and rocket history but if
you think there's anything else that
would be relevant please let me know
thanks very much for watching